as the year
12021 slowly comes to an end
we present to you
the 12022
human era calendar
eons edition
as always we're adding 10 000 years to
the regular calendar to represent the
human era and include all cultures
around the world but this year we're
expanding the scope beyond humanity to
showcase forgotten animals and plants
from all across the phanerozoic eon like
giant armored fish scythe lizards or
giant sloths on 12 elaborate pages
witness how multicellular life has
persisted for over half a billion years
surviving asteroid impacts volcanoes and
frozen oceans and of course pandemics
in the end life er
finds a way and we want to celebrate
that
you can get the very shiny high quality
limited edition now until we set out and
then never again to support what we do
on this channel to fill the void in your
soul or just to have something beautiful
to look at
as every year we also have bundles and
special calendar deals with some of your
favorite products
thank you so much to all of the
thousands of birbs who get the calendar
every year you enable us to create
videos and to publish them for free for
everyone
we wish you a happy year 12022
[Music]
you